a record 4.2 billion dollars was lost to
cyber criminals in 2020 up from 3.5
billion and a new study finds nevada's
cyber attack victims lost on average 27
hundred dollars per victim here's a look
at what you can do to protect yourself
the most financially damaging cyber
attacks are business email compromise
corporate data breach and investment
scams majority originate from countries
outside the u.s but cyber attacks
against security cameras is also surging
remember when someone hacked this nanny
cam
i'm your best friend
i'm santa claus cyber criminals are
accessing security cameras inside
vehicles schools and hospitals as well
says ceo ray ansari of cctv camera world
just like our personal computers they're
vulnerable to attack
and
a lot of that has to come from
how they're being manufactured cctv
camera world the distributor for
professional quality security cameras
for individuals large corporations and
the armed forces but ansari says a
majority of products people purchase for
personal or business use tend to be the
low-cost products manufactured out of
china he says that can put you at risk
because of the shortcuts made with the
software the low-cost products don't
have those vulnerabilities
or back doors
eliminated from their product and
nowadays the
better manufacturers that you go for
they actually make the user put in
a secure password he adds having a
strong password being aware of the many
phishing email scams out there and
having a good router with an exceptional
firewall will reduce your chances of
becoming a cyber victim
firewalls are such an important part in
keeping data traffic that we don't want
outside of our